Con cerca 10 millones de habitantes y unos
200 mil km², nuestro protagonista de hoy
es un país que últimamente ha destacado
sobre todo por tres cosas:
Primero, por ser considerado, ni más ni menos,
que como la última dictadura de Europa.
Segundo, por haber jugado y seguir jugando
un papel clave en la invasión rusa de Ucrania.
Y tercero, exactamente en esta misma línea,
por ser el único aliado europeo que le queda
a la Rusia de Vladímir Putin.
Por supuesto, estamos hablando de la Bielorrusia
de Alexander Lukashenko.
Nunca antes este país había tenido un protagonismo
tan destacado. Hablamos del país donde acordaron
refugiarse los Wagner tras amotinarse y marchar
sobre Moscú.
Y, por supuesto, también hablamos del lugar
en el que comenzó el día 24 de febrero de
2022 la propia invasión de Ucrania.
No olvidéis que la primera ofensiva rusa
partió de la región bielorrusa de Gómel.
Y eso no fue todo, además, en paralelo con
el avance de las tropas terrestres, la fuerza
aérea rusa lanzó docenas de ataques contra
objetivos ucranianos con aviones y misiles
que despegaban y se lanzaban también desde
Bielorrusia.
Pese a las históricas promesas de Lukashenko
de que Ucrania nunca sería atacada desde
su país, en los planes rusos de hacerse con
Kiev en 72 horas, Bielorrusia jugaba un papel
absolutamente clave.
("Aquellos que nos reprochan, ¿no sabían
que tenemos la alianza más cercana con la
Federación Rusa? Con ellos estamos construyendo
un estado único, poderoso e independiente:
el Estado de la Unión.
Hemos estado y estaremos juntos con la Rusia
fraterna. Nuestra participación en la "operación
especial" fue decidida por mí hace mucho
tiempo". Alexander Lukashenko, Presidente
de Bielorrusia)
Desde entonces, este ha sido, con mucho, el
país más afectado por las sanciones internacionales,
tanto a nivel económico como político. Incluso,
algunas de las empresas más conocidas del
país, han decidido abandonarlo. Hablamos
por ejemplo de Wargaming, la empresa desarrolladora
de juegos tan conocidos como este:
(La empresa más grande de videojuegos de
Bielorrusia abandona el país... y Rusia.
El desarrollador del juego de guerra “World
of Tanks” cierra sus estudios y traslada
la operativa de los juegos. Polygon)
Pero, ¿sabéis qué? Nada de esto es lo peor.
Lo peor es que transcurrido mucho tiempo desde
que arrancara la guerra, ahora ya no es la
soberanía de Ucrania la que corre peligro,
sino la de la propia Bielorrusia.
Sí, sí, lo habéis escuchado bien:
Este país podría llegar a desaparecer en
no mucho tiempo, y no precisamente por ser
invadido por Ucrania o la OTAN. Bielorrusia
corre el riesgo de terminar anexionado por
el gran oso ruso.
Sin ir más lejos, el propio Parlamento de
Ucrania considera que de facto Rusia ya lo
ha ocupado. Es prácticamente la misma posición
que mantiene la oposición bielorrusa en el
exilio.
Y esto ha hecho que en VisualPolitik nos hagamos
unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Hasta qué punto corre Bielorrusia el riesgo
de terminar anexionada por Rusia? ¿Qué estaría
detrás de las supuestas intenciones de Moscú?
¿Por qué Lukashenko parece no hacer nada
al respecto?
Pues bien, en este vídeo responderemos a
estas y otras preguntas.
Arranquemos.
Queridos amigos, amigas, Bielorrusia tiene
básicamente un gran problema:
Bajo la perspectiva de Moscú, este no es
realmente un país extranjero o uno del todo
independiente.
Más bien lo ven como una especie de territorio
autónomo que de alguna forma pertenece realmente
a la propia Madre Rusia.
Y, claro, como os podéis suponer, conociendo
todos los antecedentes, esto es sumamente
inquietante.
Pero lo peor es que no se trata de una perspectiva
exclusivamente rusa.
(Cuando Lukashenko llegó al poder en 1994
lo hizo ganando unas elecciones en las que
su campaña se basó sobre todo en la integración
con Rusia… Particularmente en el ámbito
económico, pero no solo. Digamos que en su
día Lukashenko recibió el apoyo político
y económico de Moscú a cambio de reforzar
la cosmovisión rusa.)
De hecho, la identidad bielorrusa, que durante
años ha promovido y sigue promoviendo el
propio régimen, se basa sobre todo en el
culto al pasado soviético, en la “Gran
Guerra Patriótica” - la Segunda Guerra
Mundial - y la hermandad con la propia Rusia.
Del resto del pasado de Bielorrusia… Ni
papa.
Incluso, el propio Lukashenko ha llegado a
decir en la televisión estatal que los bielorrusos,
en esencia, son "rusos con sello de calidad".
Sí, sí, así, tal cual.
De hecho, fue en gran medida esta posición
lo que explica que en 1999 Moscú y Minsk,
firmaran un tratado bilateral para constituir
progresivamente el llamado Estado de la Unión.
En otras palabras, que los dos países decidieron
fusionarse. Bueno, fusionarse, fusionarse
no, pero sí reforzar hasta el extremo su
integración social, política y económica
con instituciones conjuntas:
Hablamos, por ejemplo, de una moneda común
o un código tributario unificado.
Por ahora, no se ha llegado a tanto, pero
desde el primer momento, sí que se estableció
la libertad de movimiento entre ambos países
y la unificación de ambos mercados laborales.
De esta forma, los rusos y los bielorrusos
no necesitan ni permisos ni ningún otro documento
particular para trabajar en cualquiera de
los dos países.
Pero… Con todo, la pregunta que tenemos
que hacernos es, ¿por qué Bielorrusia decidió
dar este importante paso?
A ver, aparentemente, tenía todas las de
perder, ¿no os parece? Un país pequeño
asociándose con uno muchísimo más grande…
Está claro que Moscú terminaría tomando
todas las decisiones, ¿No es así?
Pues no, lo cierto es que no. O al menos eso
no fue lo que pensó Lukashenko… Fijaos.
(Los años 90 fueron muy duros para Rusia,
el país vivía sumergido en una constante
crisis y eso despertó la ambición del líder
bielorruso. Ya os lo hemos contado en alguna
ocasión, Lukashenko llegó a pensar que en
muchos órganos conjuntos el peso de poder
de Rusia y Bielorrusia sería exactamente
el mismo. Incluso llegó a pensar que él
mismo podría dirigir esa especie de supra-estado.
Por supuesto, el paso del tiempo hizo que
las cosas empezaran a verse de forma totalmente
diferente, hasta el punto de que hoy para
Bielorrusia no hablamos de una asociación
sino del riesgo real de anexión a Rusia.)
Y la pregunta es, ¿pero es que acaso Lukashenko
fue tan ingenuo? ¿Cómo puede ser que el
último dictador de Europa sea un tipo al
que se la juegan tan fácilmente?
Pues lo cierto es que esto no es del todo
así. El dictador ruso siempre tuvo un ojo
mirando a Rusia y otro mirando a occidente…
Hasta que un buen día todo ese cambio.
¿Qué fue lo que ocurrió? ¿Qué pasó para
que Minsk prácticamente se rindiera a Moscú?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T1(LA AMBIGÜEDAD CALCULADA)
Poco después de firmarse el Tratado del Estado
de la Unión, comenzó el super-ciclo de las
materias primas y el petróleo, que consolidó
la primera etapa de Putin al frente de Rusia.
Durante esos años los dólares empezaron
a fluir hacia Rusia como si no hubiera mañana
y, por supuesto, Bielorrusia se benefició
de toda esa repentina ola de prosperidad:
Sus exportaciones al gigante ruso se dispararon,
muchos jóvenes se trasladaron al país vecino
a trabajar y, por supuesto, la inversión
directa de compañías rusas en el país se
multiplicó. Fueron los años dorados de la
Bielorrusia de Lukashenko.
Pero, amigos, no era oro todo lo que relucía.
Había un problema, un gran problema que no
dejaba dormir al dictador bielorruso. Y es
que al poco tiempo de llegar Putin al poder,
Lukashenko entendió perfectamente que el
nuevo mandamás ruso no era como Yeltsin y
que, por tanto, sus planes de pilotar el Estado
conjunto que habían acordado crear estaban
condenados al más absoluto de los fracasos.
(Entonces en Minsk empezaron a dar largas
sobre el proyecto. Y no solo eso, cuando los
precios del petróleo se desinflaron, el gobierno
bielorruso aprovechó la ocasión para dejar
de mirar directamente a Moscú y empezar a
prestar más atención a Occidente. En la
diana estaba el gigantesco mercado de la Unión
Europea.)
Y eso ni siquiera es todo, también comenzó
a cultivar una identidad nacional propia,
una que fuera más allá de Rusia.
En 2014, por ejemplo, varios medios de comunicación
rusos empezaron a culpar al líder bielorruso
de coquetear con el nacionalismo y tratar
de suplantar la cultura rusa.
C2(“Hay una campaña rusofóbica no declarada
en Bielorrusia y se está complaciendo abiertamente
a las fuerzas nacionalistas”. Comentarista
político pro-ruso Yuriy Baranchik en 2014)
El gobierno tomó sibilinamente todo tipo
de medidas, algunas tan simbólicas como sustituir
en las celebraciones las cintas de San Jorge
- que se utilizan mucho en Rusia - por cintas
verdirojas que imitan los colores de la bandera
oficial.
También, en 2018, el régimen llegó a permitir
- y hay quien dice que hasta alentar - las
celebraciones públicas por el centenario
de la república bielorrusa que se declaró
en 1918 tras separarse temporalmente de Rusia.
El primer intento de independencia nacional
de su historia moderna. Como os podéis, imaginar,
todo un símbolo para los movimientos nacionalistas.
Pero estos, son solo dos ejemplos de un movimiento
que buscaba claramente y por primera vez reforzar
una verdadera identidad nacional.
Claro, en esa época el régimen bielorruso
ya se había vuelto mucho más precavido respecto
a la nueva Rusia de Putin. No se fiaban de
ella, sabían que de no consolidar una clara
identidad nacional y empezar a buscar alternativas
comerciales y económicas, el país tarde
o temprano sería engullido por Rusia. Incluso,
estuvieron dispuestos a renunciar a ciertas
subvenciones, a cambio de más independencia
económica y política.
En ese momento, más allá de las apariencias,
lo cierto es que las relaciones entre Minsk
y Moscú no eran precisamente las mejores.
De hecho, a comienzos de 2020 Rusia le llegó
a cortar a este país el suministro de petróleo
y restableció los controles fronterizos al
movimiento de personas.
Para que os hagáis una idea de cómo estaban
las cosas, Lukashenko se negó en todo momento
a reconocer la anexión rusa de Crimea. Para
él, Crimea seguía siendo Ucrania.
Y también decía cosas como estas:
C3(“Bielorrusia nunca permitiría que otros
países usen nuestro territorio para una intervención
militar en Ucrania”. Alexander Lukashenko,
2017.)
El problema es que lo de mirar a occidente
a veces resulta más fácil de decir que de
hacer, especialmente si eres una dictadura
con puño de hierro y tienes una economía
terriblemente obsoleta.
En el caso de Bielorrusia, básicamente lo
que podía exportar a la Unión Europea eran
commodities y productos de bajo valor añadido:
madera, metal, patatas y, sobre todo, productos
petroquímicos.
Y es que veréis, Bielorrusia tiene una enorme
capacidad instalada para producir combustibles
y derivados del petróleo. ¿El problema?
Que toda esa industria, la mayor del país,
depende básicamente del suministro ruso de
petróleo barato. Con lo que al tiempo que
incrementaba sus exportaciones al oeste, aumentaba
su dependencia de Rusia.
No era una situación fácil, pero en cualquier
caso lo cierto es que cada vez había más
distancia entre Moscú y Minsk.
Digamos que fue la gran oportunidad de sacar
de una vez por todas a Bielorrusia de la esfera
de control del Kremlin. Sin embargo, amigos,
de repente en 2020 todo este proceso se vino
abajo.
Y no, no fue por lo que estáis pensado, en
toda esta historia el responsable no fue la
Covid-19, sino las elecciones presidenciales.
Fijaos.
(El día 9 de agosto de 2020 se celebraron
elecciones presidenciales. La candidatura
de Lukashenko se hizo oficialmente con algo
más del 80% de los votos. Por supuesto, estas
elecciones estuvieron casi tan amañadas como
una carrera de atletismo en Corea del Norte
en la que participara King-Jong Un.
Y eso hizo estallar enormes protestas pacíficas
exigiendo un cambio de juego en el país.
Las protestas fueron tan grandes y contaron,
además, con tanto apoyo internacional, que
por primera vez el régimen bielorruso estuvo
contra las cuerdas. Y eso nisiquiera es todo,
para colmo los bielorrusos comenzaron a retirar
masivamente dinero de los bancos e intentaron
por todas las vías convertir sus rublos locales
a monedas más fuertes, como el dólar o el
euro, por lo que pudiera pasar. En un mes
los bielorrusos prácticamente agotaron las
reservas del banco central e instituciones
como el FMI se negaron a acudir en su auxilio.
El país estaba al borde del colapso y la
dictadura de Lukashenko parecía pender de
un hilo. Solo le quedaba una salida: echarse
en brazos de Rusia.)
¿Y sabéis qué? Dicho y hecho. Eso fue exactamente
lo que hizo.
El régimen bielorruso pidió auxilio a Vladímir
Putin, y en apenas unos días Rusia aprobó
un primer rescate de 1.500 millones de dólares.
Luego, junto a ese rescate financiero, Rusia
también prometió asistencia militar...
(16 agosto, 2020: Vladimir Putin ha ofrecido
enviar asistencia militar para apoyar al presidente
de Bielorrusia, Alexander Lukashenko, mientras
200.000 manifestantes se reúnen para pedir
su dimisión. Business Insider)
Y luego el Kremlin también envió a todo
tipo de profesionales de la propaganda y la
represión.
Sin ir más lejos, los canales de televisión
fueron prácticamente tomados por propagandistas
rusos. Propagandistas que por supuesto estaban
a las órdenes de Moscú, no de Minsk.
Amigos, amigas, sea como sea, la cuestión
es que con toda esta ayuda y con la garantía
de que el ejército ruso impediría cualquier
tipo de sublevación contra el gobierno bielorruso,
Lukashenko pudo aumentar la represión y la
persecución a toda la oposición política
sin temer las consecuencias.
En 2021, incluso, pasó esto, ¿os acordáis?
N3(23 de mayo de 2021: Ryanair confirma que
Bielorrusia ha obligado a aterrizar a uno
de sus aviones. EuropaPress)
Tal cual, la fuerza aérea bielorrusa forzó
el aterrizaje en Minsk de un avión de Ryanair
que volaba entre Atenas y Vilnius para detener
a Román Protasévich y a su pareja Sofia
Sapega. Protasevich es un periodista crítico
y activista de la oposición con asilo en
la Unión Europea.
[Un momento, ¿obligar a aterrizar a un avión
comercial europeo volando entre dos ciudades
europeas, enviando para ello incluso un caza,
y todo para detener una persona con asilo
político en Europa? Por supuesto, eso suponía
cruzar todas las líneas rojas, pero en ese
momento en Minsk, gracias al apoyo de Moscú,
se lo podían permitir.
Solo había un problema: los regalos casi
nunca son gratis. Y desde luego, en este caso
no lo fueron.
A cambio de toda esta ayuda, el dictador bielorruso
tuvo que reconocerle al Kremlin mucha más
influencia que nunca.
Incluso tuvo que comprometerse a sacar adelante
una reforma constitucional que, por ejemplo,
permitiese el despliegue permanente de tropas
rusas en el país. ¡De locos!
Por supuesto, como os podéis imaginar, todo
este proceso vino acompañado por un montón
de nuevas sanciones por parte de la comunidad
internacional, lo que, evidentemente, profundizó
aún más la dependencia de Rusia.
Digamos que la era de mirar a occidente había
llegado a su fin para siempre.
Y ahí, queridos amigos, ahí todo cambió.
Durante años, Bielorrusia se había opuesto
frontalmente a la apertura en el país de
bases militares rusas. Entendían, lógicamente,
que eso suponía una amenaza intolerable.
Sin embargo, tras el “rescate” del 2020
ya no quedó más remedio que aceptar las
exigencias rusas.
(Pero eso no fue todo. A partir del 2020 también
se puso en marcha por parte del gobierno bielorruso
una fuerte retórica antioccidental, el Estado
de la Unión volvió a primera plana, se utilizó
a decenas de miles de inmigrantes de Oriente
Medio y África para causar en 2021 una crisis
política y humanitaria en la frontera con
Polonia y Lituania y en noviembre de ese mismo
año, Minsk reconoció por primera vez a Crimea
como parte de Rusia.
Y aún más, también se puso en marcha una
intensa rusificación en el país. Hasta se
retiraron del Museo Nacional esculturas de
los gobernantes del Gran Ducado de Lituania.
A partir de ahora el pasado de Bielorrusia
solo puede pasar - al menos “oficialmente”
- por Rusia.)
Ahora bien, no son únicamente las razones
políticas, los lazos con el resto del mundo
o las cuestiones culturales-identitarias lo
que hacen peligrar la independencia de Bielorrusia.
Lo cierto es que este país está cada vez
más y más sumergido en Rusia. De hecho,
resulta difícil, muy difícil, decir que
todavía estamos ante un país independiente.
Pero, ¿Queréis saber, exactamente, de qué
estamos hablando? Pues… Atentos.
T2(UNA OPA HOSTIL)
Queridos amigos, la invasión rusa de Ucrania
hizo de Bielorrusia un estado paria y lo marginó
por completo en los mercados internacionales.
La comunidad internacional le aplicó prácticamente
las mismas sanciones que a Rusia… Con una
gran diferencia: este país no tiene petróleo,
gas ni tecnología nuclear con la que jugar
en el tablero geopolítico mundial.
De hecho, Bielorrusia no tiene nada con lo
que jugar y eso explica por qué aquí las
sanciones han sido mucho más demoledoras
que en la propia Rusia.
Por ejemplo, tan solo en los primeros meses
de la guerra, las exportaciones de Bielorrusia
a la Unión Europea se desplomaron casi un
60%, algunas de las empresas más pujantes
abandonaron el país, la industria tuvo que
despedir a más del 15% de sus trabajadores,
los salarios en los sectores sanciones se
desplomaron y en su conjunto la economía
cayó en 2022 casi un 5% siendo optimistas.
Y, claro, como ya os hemos contado, todo esto
ha hecho que hoy Bielorrusia sea mucho más
dependiente de la madre patria Rusia que nunca
antes.
Pero… Ahora bien, la pregunta que tenemos
que hacernos es, ¿Hasta dónde llega realmente
toda esta dependencia?
Pues lo cierto es que es casi total. Es tan
grande que una de las grandes vías de ingresos
públicos del país consiste en revender en
el mercado internacional una parte del petróleo
que recibe a precios subvencionados de Rusia.
Hablamos, según los cálculos de un beneficio
en 2022 de 1.700 millones de dólares solo
con esta operativa. En 2023 se espera que
sean casi 3.000 millones de dólares.
Por supuesto, en Rusia conocen esta operativa,
y, ¿sabéis qué? En última instancia no
les importa. Son ellos quienes tienen el control
del grifo de crudo. De hecho, una de las principales
exportaciones del país son los combustibles…
Producidos a partir del petróleo ruso. Algo
que durante años fue alentado por Moscú.
¿Qué mejor forma de controlar un país si
su principal industria depende exclusivamente
de ti?
Y ni siquiera se trata solo del petróleo
que revende o el combustible que exporta.
En total, más de dos tercios de la energía
que el país consume bien procede de Rusia
o bien está controlada por empresas rusas.
En otras palabras, que en el contexto actual,
si Moscú cortara el grifo, Bielorrusia prácticamente
podría quedarse a oscuras.
Pero, si os parece, vayamos más allá de
la energía.
Cerca de la mitad de toda la deuda pública
del país está en manos de Rusia; luego con
la inversión extranjera directa pasa tres
cuartas partes de lo mismo y para colmo muchas
empresas públicas rusas controlan activos
clave en Bielorrusia: hablamos de bancos,
empresas de telecomunicaciones o refinerías.
Y lo que es aún peor, se estima que hoy por
hoy entre el 60 y el 70% de todas las exportaciones
bielorrusas van a parar a la tierra de Vladímir
Putin.
Es decir, que desde un punto de vista económico
ya no podemos hablar de un país completamente
independiente.
(Todo esto explica por qué cuando Rusia quiso
invadir Ucrania y tomar Kiev en 3 días, utilizara
este país. Lukashenko no podía oponerse.
De hecho, desde que diera comienzo la invasión
de Ucrania, este país ha sido una de las
principales bases de lanzamientos de misiles,
le han entregado al ejército ruso una parte
sustancial de sus arsenales militares, les
ha permitido el uso intensivo de sus ferrocarriles
y carreteras e, incluso, se ha convertido
en un centro médico clave para los soldados
caídos o heridos en el frente,)
Pero… Un momento, esto no es nada nuevo,
¿por qué decimos que ahora existe un riesgo
real de anexión por parte de Rusia?
Pues, amigos, porque Bielorrusia puede terminar
convirtiéndose en una especie de trofeo de
consolación.
Pensadlo bien, termine como termine la guerra
de Ucrania, está claro que esta campaña
ha sido y será un rotundo fracaso. Y, claro,
a ningún tirano le gusta presentarse como
alguien derrotado.
Putin prometió proteger y hacer más grande
a Rusia… Pero eso ya no pasa por Ucrania.
Durante años Bielorrusia intento hacer malabarismos:
sacar provecho del oso ruso sin caer del todo
en sus garras. Ahora eso ya no parece posible.
Putin lo sabe y parece más que dispuesto
a sacar tajada de esta situación. Una forma
sería forzando la anexión a Rusia bajo el
marco del Estado de la Unión o cualquier
otro invento político, como la recreación
de los estados satélites de la antigua Unión
Soviética.
De esta forma podría vender una rusia más
grande y fuerte. Un éxito en el marco de
una tremenda derrota política, económica
y militar. Desde el punto de vista del Kremlin,
no es una mala jugada, ¿no os parece?
Amigos, amigas, todo apunta a que Bielorrusia
de una forma u otra puede estar a punto de
perder su soberanía, si es que no la ha perdido
ya. El intento de dar refugio a los Wagner
fue quizás el último intento de Lukashenko
de asegurarse un mayor margen de maniobra,
pero con la caída de Prigozhin eso ya es
historia.
Hoy por hoy Bielorrusia tiene muchas papeletas
de desaparecer del mapa. Sea como sea, y dado
que no tenemos una bola de cristal, si os
parece lo mejor que podemos hacer es abrir
el debate:
¿Pensáis que Rusia se anexionará definitivamente
Bielorrusia? ¿Lo convertirá en un estado
completamente subordinado o, por contra, Lukashenko
y el resto de gerifaltes de Minsk podrán
mantener el tipo? ¿Qué debería hacer occidente
ante toda esta historia?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios.
Y, por supuesto, si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante, no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros
a VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.